tenemos a fx justo aquí y está definida
en partes para bueno para x menor que
cero
fx es igual a x1 y para x mayores o
iguales que cero
fx es igual al coseno de px y queremos
evaluar la integral de menos uno a uno
de fx de x e inmediatamente podría decir
bien para cuál de estas versiones de fx
voy a sacarla antes derivada pues de
menos uno a cero caemos en el caso de x
+ 1
pero luego de 0 a 1 caemos en el caso
del coseno de px y se estaban pensando
en eso estaban pensando en la dirección
correcta y la manera en la que podemos
hacer esto un poco más fácil es en
efecto dividir esta integral definida
así que esto va a ser igual a la
integral definida de menos 1 a 0 de fx
de x más la integral definida de 0 a 1
de fx de x ahora porque me fue útil
dividir la de esta manera en particular
dividir la integral de menos uno a uno
en dos intervalos
1 a 0 y de 0 a 1 bien he hecho porque en
x igual a 0 es donde cambiamos donde fx
cambian de ser x + 1 hacer con seno de
px y si ven en el intervalo de menos 1 a
fx es x + 1 entonces aquí el fx es x + 1
y luego vamos de 0 a 1 en donde fx es
coseno de pies entonces aquí
fx es coseno de px entonces ahora solo
tenemos que evaluar cada uno de estos
por separado y sumarlos juntos así que
qué te parece si primero vamos a sacar
la integral definida de menos 1 a 0 de x
1 de x
bien vamos a ver la anti derivada de x1
es bueno primero saquemos la anti
derivada de x que es x cuadrada entre 2
sólo estoy aumentando el exponente en 1
y luego dividiendo por ese mismo valor y
luego más x y podrían verlo como si
estuvieran haciendo lo mismo si esto es
x 0 entonces me quedaría x a la 1 entre
1 que es simplemente x y voy a evaluar
esto en 0 y restarle a eso la evaluación
en menos 1 así que esto va a ser igual a
bueno si lo evalúen 0 me va a quedar
déjame ponerlo en otro color mejor el
color anaranjado me va a quedar 0 al
cuadrado entre 2 +0 bien todo eso va a
ser igual a 0 ya eso hay que quitarle la
evaluación en menos 1 entonces menos y
aquí me quedaría menos 1 elevado al
cuadrado esto a su vez dividido entre
dos más menos 1 ok
menos 1 elevado al cuadrado eso es fácil
es uno entonces me quedaría un medio un
medio más menos uno
eso es lo mismo que menos un medio pero
luego observa que estamos restando menos
un medio es 0 - menos un medio lo cual
va a ser igual a un medio positivo
entonces toda esta parte de aquí toda
esta parte de aquí va a ser igual a un
medio positivo y ahora vamos a evaluar
la integral definida desde cero a uno
del coseno de px de equis y ya que es
igual esto bueno si estamos tratando de
encontrar la derivada del coseno de x
esto ya lo sabemos es muy fácil porque
nosotros sabemos que la derivada con
respecto a x del seno de x es el coste
no de x pero eso no es lo que tenemos
aquí tenemos el coseno de px así que hay
una técnica a la que pueden llamar
sustitución um y es decir que tienen una
nueva variable llamada un y es igual a
px si no saben cómo hacerla entonces
pueden intentar pensar en en esto me lo
siguiente pueden decir qué
tal vez haya una forma de involucrar al
seno de px pero si nos fijamos en la
derivada con respecto a x del seno de px
quien sería eso bueno podremos usar la
regla de la cadena sería la derivada de
la función de afuera con respecto a la
función de adentro es decir la derivada
del seno de px con respecto a px lo cual
sería el coseno de px hasta ahí vamos
bien y luego hay que multiplicar por la
derivada de la función de adentro con
respecto a x entonces sería bueno
simplemente pib o pueden decir que la
derivada del seno de px es a veces el
coseno de px ahora ya casi lo tenemos
aquí si observas lo único que
necesitamos es un pib y si tenemos que
poner por aquí un pin multiplicando y no
queremos cambiar el valor de la integral
entonces también hay que multiplicar de
alguna manera por uno entre pib y es que
si multiplicamos y dividimos por el
mismo número no estamos cambiando su
valor uno entre pi por pi es simplemente
1 y por eso es útil porque ahora ya
sabemos qué
picos seno de px es la derivada del seno
de px entonces todo esto va a ser igual
a 1 entre pin por y ahora vamos a
evaluar entonces la anti derivada aquí
ya sabemos que es seno de px y vamos a
evaluar eso en 1 y en 0 entonces esto va
a ser igual
am me queda uno entre pin que multiplica
al seno de pi por uno lo cual es el seno
de pib menos el seno de pi por cero lo
cual es simplemente cero
entonces me quedaría el seno de pib
menos el seno de cero ahora el seno de
pib es cero y el seno de cero también es
cero entonces vamos a tener uno entre
pib que multiplica a 0 - 0 así que todo
esto va a ser igual a 0 y ya está porque
la primera parte era un medio y esta
segunda parte de aquí es igual a cero
entonces toda esta integral definida va
a ser igual a un medio más 0 lo cual es
igual a simplemente un medio entonces
todo esto
es igual a un medio